So far on Bake Off,
we've seen a tomato ketchup
upside-down cake, a boiled baba
and a sponge so massive, only Hagrid
could've polished it off.
And it's only week two.
What else could possibly happen
in that tent? Welcome...
BOTH: To The Great British Bake Off.
Last week, they tackled cakes.
Very impressed.
And Victoria was crowned star baker.
But for Natasha, it was one disaster
after another. It's all gone wrong!
This has literally been
boiled to death.
So she was the first to leave
The Great British Bake Off.
This, week the remaining 11
are under extra pressure
as they face bread.
There's no turning back now.
Understand bread, understand baking.
But who will "rise to the occasion"?
Amazing. I'm happy.
Yes. Oh, hello. Get in there.
And who will fall flat? It's
recovery from disaster at the moment.
It's different.
I don't know that I like it.
# If you're happy and you know it
Clap your hands. #
It's the second week in the search
to find Britain's best amateur baker.
The 11 remaining bakers
have a weekend of bread-making
before Mary and Paul decide
who will be this week's star baker
and who will leave.
Bakers, welcome to
the Bake Off tent again
and this week, we've got
two days of bread-making,
which of course is
Mr Hollywood's passion.
Today, it's the Signature Bake
and what we're looking for
are flatbreads.
Now, these can be tortilla, naan,
roti, anything you like,
just 12 flavoured breads,
six with yeast and six without.
You can bake them anywhere you want.
On the oven floor,
on the wall, on the griddle,
the choice is absolutely up to you.
You've got two-and-a-half hours
to complete your flatbreads, so...
On your marks. Get set.
BOTH: Bake!
Flatbreads have been popular
for centuries all over the world.
Almost all cultures
have devised a type of flatbread
based on modest ingredients and
cooking methods readily available.
This one's the trickiest one
cos it contains yeast
so it's all about making sure
that I get the rise right,
the proving right,
so yeah, that's... Tricky one first.
We're going to learn a lot
about our bakers from this challenge
because they are mostly used
to general baking,
you know, cakes, biscuits
and puddings,
and not all of them
are good at bread.
Flatbread shouldn't have
an envelope inside it.
Traditionally, it's quite a sponge
dough all the way through it
and not too thick.
The key ingredients for most
flatbreads are flour, water and salt
which when mixed into a dough,
is then rolled or flattened
to give them
their distinctive shape.
Bread is a very satisfying
thing to make.
There's this lovely
tactile feel about it
as you're kneading and proving it,
and then you get this wonderful
flavour at the end of it.
Flatbreads don't need to prove
as long as a regular loaf
as they don't rise as much,
so the main challenge
is to produce a flatbread
which is soft and easy to tear
and not snap like a cracker.
Morning, James.
All right. How's it going?
Good. I'm captivated by
your yeast slapping. Yes.
Your method you're using,
what yeast have you in there
to start with? I've got fresh yeast.
Medical student James
likens baking to medicine,
saying both involve
care and chemistry.
James is a keen
and experienced bread-baker
and today he's using
his own wild yeast
to leaven the tomato, garlic and
parmesan flatbread he's serving
alongside his tattie scones.
If you're in the Shetlands
they know how to make a sourdough,
so you won't need to buy yeast in.
Yep, well, this is
my Shetlandic sourdough.
Can I have a smell? Go for it.
It's eight years old, that one.
Eight years old? No way!
Yeah, that's nice, that,
it's nice and active.
How did you start it? Started
originally in Islay in a distillery,
so it's started with brewer's yeast.
So you've got
totally different things for us
and we're going to have
these lovely tattie scones.
I'm interested to see how
they'll be - something different.
I'm doing some coriander
and lemon naan bread
and then some garlic, parsnip
and black cardamom chapatis.
Charity head Victoria
enjoys experimenting with
different flavour combinations
and turns to her large collection
of recipes for inspiration.
I don't make bread, so I feel
like I'm sort of an imposter,
but I do like Indian food
and I've never cooked it,
so it's been adding
to my repertoire.
Morning. Morning. How are you?
Not so bad, not so bad.
So what are you doing for us?
This is my coriander
and chilli rotis.
What's in that?
A bit of butter
and some natural yoghurt.
22-year-old law graduate John dreams
of being a pastry chef in Paris.
He's baking coriander
and chilli rotis
and garlic and pomegranate pittas
topped with potato.
The beauty of the potato
with the pomegranate molasses
is that it absorbs
the sweetness and the tanginess
but also, it absorbs
the ras el hanout
and it becomes almost meaty...
I love ras el hanout. ..the potato,
so it's a great dish,
you know, for vegetarians. Yeah.
Whenever my veggie mates come over,
I always do this, you know,
as a meze, because
the potatoes just go so meaty.
You make a meze for your vegetarian
friends? I do. I love you.
Nice action, by the way. Thank you.
Very nice action. Cheers.
It's very, very easy
to overwork dough
if you use the dough hook
on the blender,
whereas it's a lot more difficult
to do that
when you're doing it by hand.
Sales manager Peter likes to
collect recipes from magazines
to bake with his son Harry.
Yummy.
A bread novice, he's baking
fennel and nigella seed naan
and a bannock bread
with a little something extra.
You've got a photograph
of Mel and Sue, is that right?
There's a very fine line here
between love and literally stalking.
I need to ask you a question.
Was it you
with the infrared night-vision
goggles by the bins last night?
I think he's seeking favour.
That'll be me.
He knows I'm not a judge. I'm just
there loving everything you bake,
eating everything you bake.
This will help you hugely.
I was young once. Tell everyone.
Tell your friends. And good-looking.
Thanks very much indeed. Thank you.
Many flatbreads are characterised
by their flavours
and Stuart is taking inspiration
from one of his favourite snacks.
One is going to be like Bombay bread
so if you've ever had Bombay Mix,
it's kind of the same flavour
and then the other one is chorizo
and spring onion naan bread.
Flavours that seem to work
and hopefully, Paul and Mary
will agree with that as well.
I'm doing a spiced mango naan bread
and a chill, lime and coriander
kind of soft flour tortilla
type flatbread.
Just making sure that I don't miss
any steps out of the recipe,
and keep an eye on the time.
So, Sarah-Jane. Yes.
What have you chosen for us?
These are the toasted
coconut and lime rotis
and I've got the oat cakes
in the drawer at the moment.
They're bubbling up, getting ready
to pour into the frying pan.
Ah, you're doing it
like a batter pancake?
Yes, like a pancake.
Have you beer in there?
I have, just a really nice
sort of pale real ale.
I'm looking forward to that one
cos obviously there will be
a pint of beer for me.
I have actually got one underneath.
Fantastic! You'll go a long way!
This is my mum's recipe
that I'm using
and I've not changed anything
so hopefully it should still work,
fingers crossed.
27-year-old nursery nurse Manisha
lives in Leicester,
but spent five formative years
in India
So she's making her family's
favourite Indian flatbread
with cumin and garlic,
as well as Italian flatbread
with sundried tomato and cheese.
What cheese have you got?
Mature cheddar. Oh! Mature cheddar.
So not a mozzarella?
You've gone for a...
No, no. Or a dolcelatte?
Mature cheddar. OK. Always good.
And what about
your non-yeasted flatbread?
The non-yeast one
is an Indian dough...
You just going to keep it
on the griddle to bake it?
Yeah, cos I normally do cook it
on a tava at home. Lovely. Lovely.
So hopefully this should be OK.
Can't wait. Looking forward to it.
OK, thank you.
After proving
and shaping the flatbread,
the bakers now have the challenge
of baking them.
Flatbreads can be baked
in various ways,
but the key is to bake them quickly
and at a very high temperature.
The intense heat
encourages the dough to expand,
turning moisture inside the dough to
steam, which helps the bread rise.
For the past two years,
I've been pursuing a project
of making breads of the world.
So far, I've achieved
about 90 of them.
Couple of hundred more to go.
63-year-old Brendan
is a keen gardener,
often helped by
his labradoodle Monty.
He has a huge bread repertoire,
and today is baking Middle Eastern
taboon bread and Indian roti
in a rather unconventional manner.
Brendan. They're calling you
"Hot Rocks" Brendan.
HE LAUGHS
Show me your hot rocks.
I'm trying to... Look at that!
What I'm trying to reproduce here,
I suppose it's a bit like
the equivalent of our stone bake.
Stone bake pizza? Yeah, exactly.
There's just an extra quality, isn't
there? An extra taste... Yeah, yeah.
It looks so nice. Thank you.
It's aesthetically
very pleasing, Brendan. Thank you.
Did you dig those up
from your garden, the rocks?
No, I went off to a certain DIY shop
and they're river-washed,
and I brought them home and washed
them and... River-washed hot rocks.
That's it! Only the best,
only the best for Brendan.
Bakers, you've got one hour to go.
Crikey. 60 minutes left
on your flatbreads.
Need to hurry up.
I've got six oat cakes to do and
they take about ten minutes each.
My maths is not great
but I think that's about right.
The griddle, or oven,
must be at optimum temperature.
Too high and the heat can burn
the outside of the bread
whilst the inside remains untouched.
Too low,
and the bread can be over-baked.
That's how it's meant to look,
sort of, isn't it?
A few sort of spots and things.
Perhaps that's a bit overdone.
The inspiration for the flatbreads
was thinking about
the sort of flavours I would like,
so I like Middle Eastern flavours
cos I've travelled a lot,
and the flour I'm using
is a kind called kamut flour
which, again, is
a Middle Eastern type flour.
Intensive care consultant Danny
likes to keep herself fit
and regularly plays racketball
with her partner Richard.
She's hoping to hit the mark with
lime, coriander and coconut tortilla
and zaatar naan with dukkah.
If they puff up like they are doing
here, then they're cooked.
The puffing up is key, really,
you want to see them puff up.
With such a large batch
of flatbreads,
managing their time is crucial.
I'm trying to juggle lots of things.
I've got the griddle on the go
and the pizza stone, and I'm trying
to remember which I put in first
and which needs to come out
or be turned over.
Keen runner Cathryn is affectionately
known at home as Last-Minute Larry
so she's meticulously planned
her time today.
She's making spiced mango naan and
lime, coriander and chilli tortillas.
Hello. She's on the griddle.
Cathryn's on the griddle. I am.
I think... I'm quite scared.
That's very damp.
That's quite unpleasant. I won't lean
on that. There's bread under there.
There's not bread... Oh, there is!
I'm so sorry, Cathryn. No, it's fine.
I was going... I'm so sorry. They
need to be flat, they're flatbreads.
You're just helping the process!
I'm really sorry.
No, that's fine, that's lovely.
30 minutes remaining, bakers.
Make sure it's done in 30 minutes
because Paul won't feel
any "pitta" for you.
Ohh!
LAUGHTER
Ohhh, come on.
I'm going to tell
your "naan" about you.
The grid I'm using now is meant to
recreate the clay pot of a tandoor,
and the blow torch,
I'm recreating the flames.
38-year-old photographer Ryan
takes his young family travelling
every year,
keen for them to experience
new cultures, sights and foods.
Oh! Molly!
He's making Shanghai paratha
and garlic and coriander naan.
Ooh, look at this!
So here I just give it
a charred effect.
Oh, dear! I charred it again.
At the moment it's a bit risky
because if it's too low,
I'll be cooking it longer,
then they go dry. Yeah.
And if it's too hot,
you can see what happens.
Oh! I'm reasonably happy.
Who'd have thought?
Usually I work with
three frying pans at a time at home,
whereas here I've only just got
one and I've got six to do,
so I've used one here,
two things at once.
Oh, hell's teeth.
All my tatties have come off.
The potatoes came off the pittas
and now they've got
bits of flour on them, but...
It'll be fine!
OK, time to slap those baps down!
Ten minutes.
Who is that?
Are you all done, Manisha?
Yep, just got to take these off.
It's sticking!
# If you're happy and you know it
Clap your hands. #
They're not coming out great.
Come on. Done!
Looks good to me.
See, perfect, no bother.
The final countdown,
it's one minute to go, please.
OK, bakers, that's time. Step away.
Step away now from the flatbreads.
Step away from the flatbreads.
Let's have a look at the texture.
Looks a nice texture.
I like the crunchy cheese
on the side.
I think I'd like
more seasoning in that. Mmm.
I really like the look
of these tattie scones.
It's a strange consistency,
isn't it? It needed longer. Mmm.
It's sort of a giveaway
when you feel it that
it is very dough-like.
But what a lovely flavour.
The flavour's lovely.
Absolutely lovely
and totally different.
The flavour's OK,
but it is quite bland. OK.
OK, your chapatis! Actually,
overall, the colour's not bad,
you expect this sort of colour.
Under-seasoned. OK.
Very salty.
Mmm. They are salty.
Taste that.
It should be half that.
I mean, really, really salty,
that is. Mmm.
They're tasty.
The flavours are good,
but I don't think you need
the salt on top. No.
These are my chilli
and coriander tortillas or rotis.
Pretty hot, pretty fiery, isn't it?
But I like them. Very good.
Thank you.
Good combination of flavours on
both of them. Thank you very much.
Well done. Thanks, guys.
They look inviting
with this nice colour.
I'm loving that. SUE: It's
delicious. It's got a great structure
and I love that garlic.
Comes through perfectly.
Good, good, thank you.
That's really tasty.
It's nice and thin.
They're fantastic, really good.
Very, very nice
and the flavour of that lime,
I adore.
It's a bit over-baked,
but it's a lovely texture inside.
OK. Thank you very much for that.
You have to really
find the chorizo in it,
because it's a shame
it's not coming through.
Every bite should contain
what you said has gone in there.
But the bake's good, you've got
a nice bake. They're nice and moist.
Thank you.
I think you've done it.
Really nice. Thank you.
I mean, really good.
I like this texture.
It makes it very moist. The colour
lets it down a little bit.
You should've blowtorched it
a bit more. Don't be afraid.
That blowtorch won't bake it.
Right. It'll colour it,
but it can't bake it. OK.
I like the structure,
I like the flavour.
It's unique, it's consistent.
Great flavour. Oh, good. Delicious.
Absolutely, it's balanced well,
the colour's good,
the texture's good.
It's full of flavour, it's lovely.
Yeah, you've got... Delicious.
..two great textures and some
unique flavours. Good, thank you.
Well done.
Thanks, Paul. Thank you, Mary.
Spicy mango.
Mmm, yes. Oh, hello. Get in there.
Oh, my goodness. That's great,
isn't it? Mmm. That's really nice.
Thank you. Really good. And pretty
unusual. Mmm. Thank you. Like that.
Your use of flavours are very good,
you've thought this through. And it
just works. Yeah, it does.
It could've been the other way
round, so that's good, isn't it?
Thank you.
Yeah, absolutely, well done.
Thanks. Good.
These are the oatcakes,
and these are the ones that have
beer in there.
I really enjoy it cos it's unique,
it's very different. Do you like it?
It's very adult.
They're very strong of beer
aren't they?
Is that going down in one?
Well done,
cos no one's thought of that,
and that for me
makes it a unique point.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Thank you.
They really liked them.
I was really surprised.
I can't really complain.
I mean, get a positive from Paul
is like, amazing.
I don't think I've done
very well at all.
The question is have I done enough
to avoid being the worst?
I don't know that I have.
Was simply complimentary.
I just stood there and blushed.
It's good to know that I still can!
With the individual style
of the Signature Bake behind them,
the second challenge
is specifically designed
so their bread-making ability
can be directly compared.
So, bakers as you know,
next up is the technical challenge
and this one is judged blind.
So Paul and Mary, I'm going to ask
you now to leave the tent.
OK, now you all know that this
is the challenge where you all
bake from the same surprise recipe.
And this week no surprises,
Paul has chosen a particularly
complicated one.
We're asking you today to prepare
and bake an eight strand
plaited loaf.
Yep, we are calling this
the Rapunzel challenge.
OK, the deal with this is we want
each plait to be the even width
and length with a nice golden crust
and a soft crumb.
You've got two hours for this bake,
OK, so...
On your marks... Get set...
BOTH: Bake!
All the bakers have the same
ingredients and same basic recipe.
But the results
could vary dramatically.
What I'm looking for is
a nice equal plait running
right the way down the length
of the bread.
And what about the texture?
It's crispy. Lovely crisp.
This is a great thing to
make for a sort of festive occasion.
It's a skill which is dying off.
A good baker should be able
to do at least one plait.
Yes we've thrown them
in at the deep end,
but we are trying to find the best
amateur baker in this country.
To start, the bakers make a simple
bread mix of flour, water,
yeast and salt.
John, James and Brendan
are all keen breadmakers.
For others, bread presents
more of a challenge.
I heard a plait and then heard eight
and I didn't even know
there was such a thing.
The added element of plaiting,
and the strong bread flour
used in this bake makes it tougher
for the dough to rise,
and requires a longer kneading
period to make it soft and flexible.
Well, it's nice to take the sort
of disappointment of the morning
and just get into a physical
rhythm by kneading the dough.
Ah, as I was kneading that it
accidentally stuck a little bit
too much to my wrist and it fell on
the floor, so had to start again.
I'll prove it for one hour,
shape it...
Well, I say shape it,
I'll be, like, knitting it.
TIMER BEEPS
Ever made an eight strand plait
before? Never in my life.
I am a constant source
of disappointment to my daughter
that I cannot plait her hair.
Not even a three plait?
Not even a three plait.
Mum to Poppy and Jacob,
28 year old Sarah-Jane
is very comfortable baking cakes,
biscuits and desserts,
but is a novice
when it comes to bread.
We've give you a slight
pattern here...
Yeah, but what does this mean?
AO52U3O8?
You've run ahead with yourself.
Look, for the following sequence O
equals over and U equals under...
Oh, OK. So place the eighth under
the seventh,
and then over the first.
What, the seventh...
I can tell you no more than that.
And the eighth?
What does it mean?
I don't understand.
I'm just going to end up
with a lump.
While their dough is proving,
so called because the reaction
of the dough rising proves
the yeast is working, the bakers
practise the plaiting technique.
And six, seven over one.
This is complicated.
How come you've got extra dough
with which to practise
this fiendish plait?
Because I accidentally dropped it
on the floor. However...
Was that accidentally on the floor?
"Oh, I've dropped it,
"I'll have to use
to experiment with!"
It's kind of gone to my favour
really, so... It has, yeah.
When he's not teaching PE,
26-year-old Stuart hits the recipe
books to come up
with new flavour combinations
to test out on his fellow teachers
in the staff room.
Ever plaited anything before?
Big plaiter? I've done
a three plaited loaf before...
Yeah?
..but never an eight.
Eight's quite an ask isn't it?
It is.
This to me...
..looks like a knitting pattern.
I can't knit either. Nor can I. No.
Stu might be a knitter, look,
he's done quite a neat job.
I think Stu might be a knitter,
I think you're absolutely right.
Secret knitter Stu.
Hobbies include PE and knitting.
When happy that the dough is proved,
the bakers focus on the most
technical -
and, for most, unfamiliar -
part of the recipe.
To achieve an even plait,
each strand should be exactly
the same length
and width before attempting the
complicated plaiting instructions.
It's 106 grams per portion.
OK, that's pretty precise, yep.
So this is per strand is it?
Per strand.
Right, to make the octopus.
Per strand,
and it needs to be that long.
I haven't done any of the kind
of fancy weighing out,
but I figure if they're all roughly
the same thickness,
but I might've completely
stuffed it up.
I'm feeling like this could go
horribly, horribly wrong.
Eight under seven over one.
Eight over five,
two...under three.
Eight under seven...
..and then seven...over one.
Don't know.
Seven goes over one
which is over here, no,
is that right?
How can I mess that up?
Six over one.
What I love about this particular
challenge is after a while
everyone sounds like Rain Man.
OK!
Eight over five, five over two.
Two under three.
Over eight. That's it.
One, two, three, four, five.
SHE LAUGHS
Oh, dear. This is like the
Generation Game gone bad. Oh, no.
Look at everybody. I'm going again.
Look at the state of my tentacles.
Poor tentacles!
It's a long time
since I've seen tentacles like that.
Two under three. Over eight.
Two under three.
I don't know if it's right or not.
I kind of free-styled
a bit towards the end.
Really disappointed,
it's a disaster.
Oh, look at James's.
It's really long.
The final part does look
reasonably plait-esque.
Not as pretty as John's,
but it'll do the job.
I'm a bit worried. This is where
I scrunched it together
to start it off.
If I give it a quick
Paul Hollywood nip and tuck,
it should be all right.
'Once complete, the plait should be
proved again for at least 30 minutes
and for some, time is tight.'
Two under three.
I'm running out of time.
I just did a bit of guesswork, more
than following the instructions.
'Before going into the oven, the egg
the bread should be egg washed
to give the crust colour and shine.'
There's no turning back now.
As long as one of the plaits
don't un-ping and the
whole thing will unravel.
Oh, go in!
Just hoping that taste, texture,
will overcome
the shortcomings in presentation.
Ladies and gentlemen
of the baking community,
you have got ten minutes left
on your plaited technical challenge.
Technically,
this is absolutely rubbish.
There is nothing good about
this loaf. He's going to hate it.
'The recipe requires the loaf
to be baked until ready,
'which could be anything
between 20 and 30 minutes.'
It should be done, but I just do not
know. Getting the oven glove ready!
Right.
Oh, hello!
Bring her over. Done.
Oh! Lovely. Good sound. Yes.
Very good, Brendan.
I'm not convinced it's the best
looking plait in the world.
Get off, get off! Argh!
It's got stuck.
Got a bit of a hole in it there,
but it's all right.
Oh, my giddy aunt!
Let's present it.
Honestly, it's really not bad.
What's wrong with that?
Sounds hollow.
Oh, dear!
Worked! Yay!
Come on, you beauty!
OK, bakers, the bread braiding
tournament is now over.
If you'd like to bring up your
loaves
and place them behind the picture
of yourself on the altar. Thank you.
'Mary and Paul are looking
for a rich colour on top,
'an even plait and a crumb structure
that springs back into shape.'
There's a spread of varying
grades of plaiting.
We'll start with this one.
It's not too bad, this one. But you
can see it's ruined at the bottom.
It's good flavour. Tastes OK.
This one seems to have got rather
a large bit at the end.
It's got a nice crust.
Now this one...
It's dancing about a bit,
isn't it? Yes.
The plait's lost its way
pretty much from the start.
There's been a little mouse
underneath here, a little hole.
A little rat's boring in there.
This one is not too bad.
See how straight it is
down the middle? Not bad at all.
Nice crust on it.
I'm quite impressed with that one.
It's not bad at all.
And, again, good flavour.
This one's gone awry again.
It needed longer baking.
Tastes OK, but no crust
and that's down to the bake.
What do you reckon on that one,
Mary? I think it's unusual. But
they got it right down the middle.
Yeah, they started off poorly.
The middle was pretty good and
then tailed off badly at the end.
A lot of flour's been used on this.
See the line.
Yes, it's quite divided there.
Now... Nice glaze on it.
Go on, say something nice.
It's got a nice glaze on it, but
it's like raw dough in the middle.
That is dough. The plait is...
To say it was a disaster would
be a humiliation to disaster.
It just looks a little bit informal,
not quite what we're asking for.
Let's have a look inside.
It's barely baked.
I know that if you squeeze it like
that, it's sticking in a ball.
It's going back to dough. Yeah.
Um...
Not bad.
It's quite uniform, the shape.
It's pretty good in the middle.
Tastes OK. This one looks as though
it hasn't been kneaded long enough,
or it's been rushed.
It's breaking up far too easily.
Yeah, it's had a few problems,
this one. Very dense inside.
Bordering on raw. It's underdone,
isn't it? It actually tastes OK.
It's lovely.
Now...
Oh, dear. What happened there?
It stuck to the tray, basically.
It's probably going
to be quite raw inside.
Yeah.
Which moves me onto this one,
which is near perfect. Nice colour.
There's a bit of folding underneath.
It's got a nice crust to it.
The plait should look like wood.
Lovely crust on it, good flavour.
It's the best looking.
Very good-looking bread.
'Paul and Mary will now reveal
how the bakers have fared.'
In last place is this person here.
That's me.
Obviously, you know the problems
that you had. OK.
In tenth place is this one.
That's me. What happened to
the bottom? It got stuck?
It got stuck on the baking tray.
OK, just be careful
with your plaits as well.
In ninth place is Stuart,
followed by Cathryn in eighth,
Victoria is seventh
and for the second week in a row,
Manisha is sixth.
In fifth place is Ryan.
A little bit under-baked.
Yeah, the dough needed
a little bit more working.
And in fourth is Brendan
and in third place is Danny.
In second place is this one.
It's pretty good. Well done.
So, we all know who is number one.
APPLAUSE
That went phenomenally well,
amazingly well. Yeah.
It didn't look perfect,
but it was a plait.
You would look at it and say,
"That's a plaited loaf."
Paul just said it was
pretty disastrous and it was.
I'm going in tomorrow
with the attitude that I'm going
to be relaxed about it
and I hope that dough
feels the love!
'With just one challenge to go,
before Mary and Paul's decision,
how are the bakers faring?'
Who's doing well, Mary?
Brendan is doing rather well.
His flatbreads were good.
And also Ryan. He did very well.
He did.
And also, we should perhaps
point out John,
who came first in the plait.
He really got the plait right.
Looking at the other end
of the group, who do we think
is in danger this week?
Peter. His plait was under proved
and inside, a bit doughy.
I'd throw Victoria in there.
Ironically, star baker
from last week.
I think the winner of Bake Off will
be somebody who is consistent.
They've got a bagel challenge now.
I've think that will separate
the wheat from the chaff,
if you'll excuse the pun.
And by your face, you won't.
And I accept that.
Bakers, welcome back for
the final challenge of this weekend,
the Showstopper Challenge.
We're asking you to attempt
a technique that has never
been done on this show before,
icing a cupcake
whilst bungee jumping.
I jest. Of course,
it's bread week.
We're asking you to use poaching
techniques, as well as baking.
We're asking you today
to bake and present 24 bagels,
12 savoury and 12 sweet.
And you can work your own special
flavours into the dough
or you can bake them on the top,
or you can do both.
Just remains to say...
On your marks... Get set...
BOTH: Bake.
'Bagels are a type of bread,
but their unique chewy texture
'presents the bakers
with a new challenge.
'The bagels are poached
before they go into the oven.'
'The texture of a bagel
should be chewy,'
soft, good skin on the outside,
a beautiful golden brown.
More importantly,
have a hole in the middle.
All the bakers start off
in the same way,
by preparing a basic dough,
containing a strong wheat flour.
It's always good to get going.
Glad to be in the final straight,
as it were. All to play for still.
Both of these recipes
in their current manifestations,
these are the first times
I am making both of them.
Paul and Mary are going to be the
guinea pigs for these recipes, yeah.
That's a bit scary actually.
Probably should have practised.
James's sweet offering is flavoured
with orange, mint and chocolate.
And for his savoury Millers' bagels,
he's attempting a tricky
and time-consuming sourdough.
A sourdough bagel with no yeast in
it at all. No yeast in it at all.
That's brave.
In four hours, yeah! It is, very.
Some of my sours will take up to
eight or nine hours throughout,
some of the bigger ones.
To do it in four,
and sweet ones as well...
You're the first one on Bake Off
to actually use sours in this way.
So well done.
'By adding different flavours
to their bagels,
'the bakers must adjust
their recipes to prevent
any reactions that may occur
'whilst they prove, boil and bake.'
I had a sticky situation whereby
I soaked the dates overnight,
made sure it's moist, but then
over-soaked too much liquid.
As soon as I put the dates into
the dough, it went too wet.
It's really sticky dough.
Ryan's sweet bagels are made
with cinnamon and dates.
And his savoury bagels
with tarragon and rosemary.
Can I have a look at it?
Do you mind? Of course.
It's quite soft. Is that the date
one? Yes, I was a bit worried.
It stuck and it would affect
the texture of the dough. It can.
It might be denser.
I'm worried, but it's done now.
- Good luck with it all.
- Thank you.
< See you in a bit.
'After the dough has proved,
the bagels are ready to take shape.
'There are various methods
to achieve this and Brendan is
adding an unconventional twist.'
You simply pinch the ends
and then you gently rock backwards
and forwards.
For my savoury bagels,
I'm going to shape them
in the modern way of piercing
the thumb and that way.
I thought one traditional,
one modern.
To complement his chocolate
and vanilla sweet bagels,
Brendan's savoury bagels are
flavoured with cumin and Gruyere.
What inspired this?
You could have done just a classic
one flavour plain bagel, but no.
I thought I might as well learn
how to make a bagel twist
at the same time.
That sounds like the beginning of
joke, how do you make a bagel twist?
I'll come back to you
with a punchline!
The best way of doing it
is the most traditional.
Traditional ways are often the best
and they can often be forgotten.
This way, although it doesn't
give the most even of rings,
I think I quite like it.
It looks quite rustic, homely,
sign of a home-made bagel.
It's important to get
a nice even ring, I think,
just for the look factor.
It's that finesse they do look for.
And they do mark you on that.
John's savoury fig bagels
will be topped with walnut
and Gruyere cheese
and his blueberry bagels will be
lightly covered in white chocolate.
Hello, John. Hello.
I want to talk about your action.
You're using the middle finger spin,
I noticed.
It's more of a spin and squeeze,
so you can try and get uneven
consistency all the way round.
- And then I just sort of...
- The double-hander.
Just so you can try
and get an even consistency.
'Poaching the dough before baking
'gives the bagels their dense, chewy
texture
'and creates a skin that
will brown and crisp when baked.
'Over boiling will result in the
crust being too thick and too chewy,
'but if the dough is not solidified,
'it will rise in the oven and
produce bread rolls, not bagels.'
If you're not careful in putting it
in the water, it's got a tendency
to actually collapse on itself.
They don't puff
up as much as they should.
So, bagels, how confident
are you feeling? Not very. ..three.
Count again. Four, five. Six, seven.
Sorry, eight. Welcome to technology.
Does that do seconds? Yes.
Let's reset. There you go, poppet.
What are you on now? 20.
Ten seconds. We'll do the next one.
So this is the part cooking
and puffing of the bagel. Yes.
Can we press that? One, two.
There you go, excellent.
I can... Relax. Relax, yeah.
Let technology take the strain now.
It's because they're so soft,
I'm worried that when I boil them
and mess around with them,
they'll break up.
I'm not... Oops!
Oh, my God!
Once in the oven, it's a nervous
wait, as the bake will reveal
whether the bagels will hold their
shape or rise like regular bread.
I don't know. The holes have closed
up loads. They look like rolls.
It's impossible to know what they're
like until you cut into them.
And they're probably going
to be completely wrong.
I am worried that I'm always last.
I haven't messed around today
though.
I've done what I needed to do,
but obviously I needed
all the time that I had.
It's not exactly going to plan.
It's more like a recovery
from disaster at the moment.
They're as synonymous with
New York as yellow taxi cabs,
Andy Warhol and loud, short,
bad-tempered comedians.
But we Brits have actually been
brunching on the bagels
for a lot longer
than our Stateside cousins.
So where do bagels actually
come from? Tell me, already!
'The earliest recorded bagels
were baked by the Jewish communities
in 17th century Poland.
'Given as gifts at circumcisions
and funerals,
'their shape was said to represent
the circle of life.'
So when did bagels first
go international?
In the late 19th century, millions
of Jews left Eastern Europe.
They were escaping persecution
and economic hardship.
For many, the first port of call
was London.
Jewish communities sprang up,
particularly in the East End
of London and in Manchester.
What do we know about the early
British bagel traders?
They tended to be street-sellers.
They were a cheap bread
that was sold in the street,
usually by women.
They became known as
the Bagel Queens of the Lane.
The lane being Petticoat Lane
in the East End.
There's one rather wonderful
description of the bagels themselves
as being always oven-fresh,
geometric in their roundness
and shining like a good deed
in an iniquitous world.
'These bagels were made to be
kosher,
'made in strict accordance
to Jewish dietary laws.
'A procedure that's still
followed today.
'A local rabbi closely monitors
this bakery in North London.'
Rabbi Conway,
how do you ensure the bagels
are being made in a kosher way?
Well, first of all,
we have an inspector
who comes in at least once a day.
First thing he does is he has to
make sure that all the ingredients,
all the products,
everything being used here
is firstly not of animal origin
and secondly not of dairy origin.
And how does Sabbath affect
the bagel making process?
It doesn't affect it at all,
because there's no baking of kosher
bagels on the Sabbath.
This bakery, for example, they have
to close at sundown on the Friday
and they have to stay closed
until Saturday night
when three stars can be seen
in the sky.
So for 25 hours, there is no baking.
'By the mid-20th century, the bagel
in Britain was still largely
'the preserve of Jewish communities,
'but over in New York,
had become mainstream.'
When the bagel making machine
was invented in 1963,
this meant that American bakers
could mass produce
and distribute
their bagels nationwide.
Their popularity increased.
These new American-style bagels
were bigger and sweeter
and available in a huge variety
of different flavours.
They were soon rebranded
and marketed back to us
as an American speciality.
The '80s and '90s
saw a bagel boom in the UK.
So if you asked a New York cabbie
to follow that bagel home,
he might have a bigger fare
than he expected.
Well, some are split on the top.
They've risen up a bit.
They've got not a bad crust,
slightly over-cooked there.
Like the curate's egg -
good in parts.
SHE SIGHS
They look lovely.
Ah, that smells great!
Oh, I don't know!
To be honest,
there's so many issues with these.
I think I'm in trouble today, yes.
Amazing. I'm happy.
I'm really happy with them.
Paul just gave them a little
bit of a glance. I know, I saw that.
Doesn't give anything away though.
Really unnerving, yeah.
OK, bakers. That's ten minutes left,
please. Ten minutes remaining.
String 'em up!
Like a bagel-y washing line.
I think that's marvellous.
That's the best use I've seen for
a mug tree since mugs went on it.
Do you think quite a lot
about your presentation, James? No.
Just put them on a board?
Put them on a board.
I'm not sure what it looks like.
It looks like twelve beautiful
bagels on a board, James.
OK, bagels shmagels.
This challenge is over.
'Each baker's offering
will be individually judged
'before Mary and Paul make
the decision as to who is leaving
'The Great British Bake-Off.'
The porcini mushroom flavour is
coming through and the cheese too.
The way they look is a bit...
They're a bit weak, a bit flat.
But the taste and texture
is all right.
And your sweet one.
I like the flavour of those.
The shape of those are better
than your savoury ones.
They're more like bread rolls
than they are a bagel.
You overbaked them.
It's a very close texture
and a rather hard crust.
It's a bread roll
with salt and herbs on top,
not a bagel unfortunately.
They've all been over-proved.
They all look...
You've got a very bread-like...
and it's quite flat.
And you've lost the shape. Yeah.
These are the cranberry ones.
I'm not getting strong cinnamon.
If you get a bit of a cranberry,
it kind of...
I've got a lot of cranberry.
Oh, OK. Fair enough.
They're both over-proved.
They look...not like bagels.
You've got a very good batch,
all matching.
You rather like that, don't you? Mm.
Gruyere's lovely, and the cumin.
If we move onto your sweet "bagels".
In inverted commas, because that
to me is like a bread ring.
It's not a bagel. Right.
It's different. Mm.
I don't know that I like it. It just
needed some added sweetness for me.
The sour and the bitterness
of the chocolate...
You could class that as a savoury,
if you pushed it. Oh, right.
Great idea, but needs to be
thought through a little bit more.
Worked on.
I felt the dough and I thought
it was a bit soft.
It's pretty much what's gone wrong.
It's just concertinaed up
into a flatbread, which was earlier.
You're very good with your flavours.
I like that.
It's an interesting flavour,
but it's not exactly a bagel.
It's a new bread you've invented.
A flagel!
The crunch is lovely
from walnuts and cheese.
I like the idea
of the white chocolate on top.
Did you have sugar with that dough?
No, just honey. It's overbaked then.
Overbaked? OK. But the flavours
are lovely. Absolutely lovely.
The fact that you've managed
to come up with something
related to sour in four hours
is admirable.
That's interesting.
Yeah, well done.
LAUGHTER
He finds it painful to say that!
Very tricky to do.
I think out of all of them, it was
probably the hardest one to make.
Now, orange and mint?
Yeah. Overbaked.
Yeah. Too much colour underneath.
You had an awful
lot of orange in here.
I can certainly taste it,
and I like it.
And the mint is now coming through.
The overall flavour, I think
it's good. It's a nice bagel.
They look great,
but I'm more impressed with them.
Well done. Thank you.
That went absolutely fantastic.
Better than I could have
possibly hoped.
It was absolutely brilliant.
Yeah, there are no words.
Oh dear, oh dear! Disaster!
'Paul thought my bread rolls
were really good,'
but unfortunately
we were doing bagels this afternoon.
I think I'm probably
the one to go today.
I really do think
it could be anybody.
So, Paul and Mary,
who is in the arena this week
for star baker, do you think?
John has got to have a mention.
In the technical challenge,
he made a beautiful loaf.
And good bagels, good texture,
good toppings. Yeah.
I actually think James
has done exceptionally well.
These sour bagels are really
difficult to do.
Brendan delivered certainly
one extremely good bagel.
The only issue I did have
was with the chocolate one.
It was far too bitter.
Let's talk about people who haven't
done quite so well this week.
Stuart is in a bit of trouble.
Didn't really do well
in the technical challenge.
Look at the bagels,
they're quite flat.
And then Peter didn't do
so well with his flatbreads.
We had that problem with salt.
He was last in the technical
challenge yesterday.
Which automatically puts you
in a very precarious position.
But, I mean, Victoria. They're not
the best bagels in the world.
You've got three in contention
for Star Baker
and three very much in contention
for the drop zone. Yeah.
We'll leave it to you to figure
it out. Go decide, Paul and Mary.
Bakers,
an exceptionally busy weekend
and you've all excelled yourself.
You should be very proud.
Of course, every week,
we like to award one of you
with the accolade of Star Baker.
This week, that accolade goes to...
..John. Well done, John.
Thank you.
And, of course,
sadly we have to announce
who will not be joining us
for next week's Bake Off.
And I'm sorry to say that
the person is...
..Peter.
Can we give you a massive
Mel and Sue sandwich,
the like of which you could only
have in your worst nightmare?
It's been fantastic.
I've had a great time, thank you.
I'm going home
and I'm absolutely gutted.
Everybody has to be experimental
and it has to be sheer perfection,
and he didn't quite reach that.
I feel very lucky. Very lucky.
I just want to show what I can do
and instead of being at the bottom,
be at the top.
Completely elated. I feel amazing.
A massive shock, to be honest.
I'm chuffed to bits.
All past winners of Bake Off
have done well on the bread week,
so I'll be watching John
very closely.
I'm going to come away from this
and it's going to be my challenge
in the next few months
to become a better bread baker.
'Next time, the bakers
take on tarts...'
You need biceps for that. Puff
the magic pastry, here it comes.
'..with a Signature Challenge that
turns everything upside down...'
Look at that!
'..a technical treacle tart
that gets them in a twist.'
If you don't get it right,
it could be the end of it.
'..and a fruity Showstopper
that pushes their pastry limits.'
It's the one who can keep
their nerves in check who will win.
Arrgh!
Subtitles by Red Bee Media Ltd